I'm kind of sick right now I am sick
right
[Music]
now people talk about say Like a Rock
Bottom before you could bounce and then
and then get back you guys are now one
lost away from you know the alltime
Mark is that on your mind and does it
almost feel like you can't get out of
like can't get out of this point yeah
it's definitely on my mind I mean that's
history that nobody wants to be part of
so
um you know what I'm saying we're trying
to we're trying to build something
that's sustainable it's not like we're
trying to just go out there and win one
game we want to win multiple
games but to be on the wrong side of
history I
mean nobody wants to be there so
um that that is definitely a extra Edge
that we have to have
and we should have won this
game but we didn't so we got to come
back next
game and be locked in and be more solid
I got to come in be locked in and be
more solid down the stretch for
us I know you guys like each other
personally but just where you guys are
right now and kind of this this journey
to to today do you think this particular
group can can turn it
around yeah we're not 2 and 26 bad you
know what I mean
like no way are we that bad how do you
explain there isn't one um I I want to
be really careful with my words cuz this
one hurts more than um many of them just
because of the
situation um a team that played last
night
gets 50 points off of rebounds and
turnovers Second Chance points and
turnovers so that this one's
um unbelievably hard to understand how
we can get outworked uh
in those categories and I you
know that is absolutely on me
just for whatever reason
um it's been the same story all year
long with those two categories
particularly the turnovers and
um it's a tough one to
swall where do you go from here we just
we got to get to work we got to show it
we got to teach it we got to demand it
and uh it's not going to change because
we feel bad about it we got to get to
work mentally where is this team close
you can just about imagine I mean you
have these kinds of opportunities you've
lost 25 in a row like you're probably
not not in a great mental state but
again what choice do you have but to
fight and compete and dig your way out
of it but it's human nature to feel like
you know you know what and that's that's
where we are do you sense a lack of
confidence in like I guess moment of
where game are close and you can grab it
and maybe it leads to the turnovers and
some of them you sense any of that I
don't I don't sense the lack of
confidence I just there's just a lack of
execution there's a lack of you know
knowing what we should do or you know we
have we've had Shots tonight we had a
couple of open threes we couldn't put
them down um I wouldn't say that's a
lack of confidence we just we've missed
those
shots